hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I'm Cody Melcher and this is Tamara
justice' and Cody also just saw two as
well unpopular opinions do all the boys
I've loved before and all the ones I
still will next to all the boys I've
blocked on Twitter all the boys I'm
awkwardly stood near trying to figure
out a way to like accidentally bump into
them so we can talk a little bit but
they wanna thinking about that they move
and then I turn around they're gone and
I'm standing a room for no reason and
then the teacher comes in and goes means
room I go paper before tonight Cody and
I watched to all the boys I've loved
before which is a huge hit on Netflix
right now yes people are going crazy
BuzzFeed especially is going crazy it's
all abuzz I want to be clear on my side
we we we watched the movie I I looked in
the general direction of it and and my
and while my eyes slowly moved gently in
different directions and then I would
and then I forced my head back towards
it I was present for the duration of the
film and no one can take that away from
I did watch the thing I liked almost
every individual part of the movie
separated from the whole and each
other.if on paper and also if you showed
me certain screenshots probably and if
you showed me certain aspects if you
told me a little bit of the storyline I
probably would have been really into
this and I came into it whole hog ready
to go because I had heard friends of
mine that were like I love this movie
and I was like I'm ready to like this
movie as well I love the idea of her
writing five deeply passionate and
personal love letters and then those
being seen terrifying
I love the Asian centric cast love it I
love Netflix originals and also we've
done a Netflix original before it was a
not good but it was fun and did well so
like I was excited about that
um Death Note
oh I was like a very I was very ready to
just love this movie the script was so a
word that you used it is so sick Comi I
don't think the script will lending
itself to the actors at all and I think
that really hindered them deeply I
thought that like the payoff of like the
story and on a whole was just the most
obvious thing yeah Rises we were talking
about how I was a dr. Strangelove Alex
Strangelove that's a Netflix original
that like no one was talking about but I
feel like everyone should have been
talking about it was so good but we were
saying it felt like maybe we didn't do
as good because it kind of felt like the
same thing as love came out of time time
times love Simon I think part of the
problem that we're having is actually
part of why it's successful perhaps if I
may put forward please theory so the
problem with the script is that it is
enamored with how clever it is the
reason why I felt state companies it
felt very much like a like an early
Audis grunge remix of sitcom that kind
of like that 70s show Freaks and Geeks
ish type thing and I liked freaks and
geeks a lot but it felt very much kind
of like that it was that kind of Airy
much of that era and so I think people
our age loved those loves that kind of
thing and so it feels very comfortable
in that way I think the problem is is
when you're going in expecting it to be
something different yeah it's like how I
talk to you about Mamma Mia where the
movie Mamma Mia feels like it's a movie
a TV movie reboot of an old sitcom from
the 70s that everyone loved and now
they're trying to bring the daughter and
so they can kind of refresh it and do
like a mommy of the next generation or
something because they introduce all of
the main characters or mommy as if you
know who they are and you've always
loved them and you're supposed to like
clap when they come on screen it's
trying to be that kind of Alti hipstery
super clever Daria inspired thing but
the problem is is it doesn't really know
what
is and they in it it's a pastiche of
that instead of just being that like
it's it's not it's not genuine it's just
kind of like what if we had a lot of
really cool jokes thrown together cuz
like you said the idea like the letters
is amazing and it was for the first 20
minutes of the movie and then they
dropped that entirely created this giant
problem and solved it immediately which
as somebody who witnessed rewriting
school is the thing they tell you not to
do I'm out of town this week that's why
we're doing this Netflix show for this
one and so tonight we also went and saw
8th grade which we did last week and you
said about 8th grade it's something
really lovely versus this one so 8th
grade did a really good job of showing
you everything and this movie did a
really good job or not maybe you're not
really good job but it this movie just
told you ever told you teenage angst
told you you know weird internal
struggles about things this had every
piece that it could like they wanted it
to be good like it had a gay beautiful
lovely character that like helped your
main character and like it had this
which is unfortunately also a trope but
the fun gay guy who also does the face
mask who also has insight into your care
was a let me be all of these magical
things for you yeah here's I'm gonna say
and this is probably the boldest thing
I'll say in this review I felt like a
really good grad student film like with
a high ass exactly that's the really
good part it was definitely a script
that probably needed a producer or a
couple of other rewrites on it the shots
the the framing is very someone grew up
really loving specific directors and
this is their first movie so they're
gonna put all the shots they've always
wanted to do you know like I'm surprised
there weren't more Dutch angles and like
Rach
yeah it was there's so much cheese and
like not them the biggest glaring issue
is that it wasn't genuine at all like
people are praising it and I think it's
because it's so fun and it's pretty and
like also it's got a cast that you don't
see very often
and it's it's lovely but it's not
genuine and that's like such a big
problem that's a decent Netflix movie
and I think if you and I had like you
know had some drinks and just been
hanging on the couch and not doing it
for this show right and we'd had some
popcorn I think we could have we could
have probably just been like yeah this
is fun you know it's a it's a movie that
you rent from Blockbuster back when
those existed and you just win you know
you got your friends together there's
one left in Oregon but you know you like
it's just that it's that movie none of
them really felt like bad actors right
that's yes yeah but it was just like
something wasn't clicking
yeah and this is like scary to say
because like everyone loves this film I
put on Twitter a post it was like we're
watching a movie that we don't like it's
on Netflix any guesses and we really mad
in the picture and somebody was like
well it can't be so all the boys I've
loved before because that's so amazing
it's like I know everyone loves it I
know I'd say yeah so with eighth grade
like being like gotta keep you very Dave
grade we did you see both them the same
night great but with eighth grade it's
like things are believable when they
happen yeah and then this one the big
the only curveball they do throw us is
she kisses the guy that she's fake
dating but everyone thinks they're
dating in a hot tub in high school and
that gets a picture of that or a video
of that goes around and that's much like
a sex tape which a it's literally just
them kissing in a hot tub and it's her
boyfriend and also like everyone treats
her really badly and I'm like that is
not the experience of my high school
life was like oh you might have had sex
with your boyfriend
wow what a horrible person it was not a
thing that happened in my high school at
all people were having sex constantly in
my high school and if anything you got
picked on if you weren't having sex and
also this wasn't sex this was kissing
your boyfriend in the hot tub right like
this she I
maybe like bringing in the shame of like
oh man you like yeah we're like if you
were us like if it was like slut-shaming
right but it's very unclear and also
deny it you're having a tender moment
with your boyfriend yeah how dare you
you're a man and a woman can't be in a
hot tub at the same time it was a it was
a well that's Genesis 37 right I forgot
about Genesis 37 yeah and then hot tub
closet forgot about it all wrapped it
very fast she was like can you defend me
for once and he's like yeah sure and
then he did it and then she was like
like by the book it's all very like okay
this is gonna happen this yeah yeah the
plot felt like it was taken out of like
a book I love love I love laughing I'm
ready to go on all of those as long it's
not the emoji movie and we'll boss maybe
I don't think with a Robin Cobb I guess
I'm interested just to hear like because
I know a lot of people are gonna be like
heated in the comments cuz people write
this movie I just want to know like why
you look identified with it or like why
I brought you joy oh oh maybe they're
just like an easy watch or like why was
it because it had like a diverse cast
which I I get but like why why and if
you're upset by anything that I said in
this review you can tweet me at Neil
Gaiman on Twitter let me have it thank
you so much for watching I will see you
all next week
[Music]